the thing that
john and i are really excited about is
we're shooting a documentary right now
um about eddie murphy we're doing with
angus wall
academy award-winning editor great
documentarian
um we've made five movies with eddie and
we've loved and adore him i
love eddie i love him as a person i love
him as a performer
you know we love and adore him and we're
doing his last stand up with him
and we're you know and it's going to be
the last time he didn't stand up it's
going to be called the last stand and
we've been working on that for two and a
half years
so you've been filming for two and a
half years with him no no no no
no we've been conceptualizing
but we have something that came in
between terrible
pandemic which kind of put the stand up
on hold but we've been shooting the
documentary
i'm assuming you're going to be shooting
when he starts eventually getting back
on stage
and following him around when that you
know once the pandemic clears i think
there's already been hours and hours and
hours and hours of footage shot with him
talking about um his early days in the
business
his perception of comedy people
influenced him
you know understanding what the life of
a stand-up is
you know what makes him different from
other stand-ups
right um it's really cool interesting
stuff
to be able to be that close to comic
genius
is really one of the great
benefits of being in this business for
me personally i mean come on we get up
we're producing eddie murphy's
stand-up special i mean i i literally as
a 13 year old
would quote delirious the entire i mean
as 13 and my parents like i mean
i mean i'm doing a whole bit you know
and my parents like are you out of your
mind
it is it's like a little kid in me can't
believe that we get to be involved with
this
the michael jordan doc was amazing
10-part series
i loved every part of it with someone
like eddie
this could be a 100 hour dock and i
would still probably watch it
my question is are you do you even think
this early on
on how long it might be or what it might
be or do you sort of have to
take all the footage in and then decide
we're shooting hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours
you know angus wall who's our director
um has gotten you know unrestricted
access to eddie and his shot and
you know eddie's home he's got nothing
to do right so it's like he's gotten
hours and hours and hours and hours
you know of filming eddie just opening
up and speaking
you know honestly and from his heart and
we're gonna get
every major comedian who eddie was
inspired by
and they're gonna talk and and and so
i think what you do is you just see how
long it should be once you're done maybe
it's 10 episodes maybe it's 15
maybe it's three you know you'll you'll
see what plays